foreign
side is the founder of Rebel Coast
Winery which is actually the world's
first Winery to ever go through a tech
incubator and the reason why I wanted
him to come because he is the most
unorthodox startup founder I've ever met
he's a pretty wacky dude but he's been
able to successfully have his
personality bleed into his brand and uh
that's what he's going to be talking
about so uh please welcome chip Forsyth
so my brother and I started making wine
in college originally to meet girls and
that did not work out at all so we ended
up having a ton of wine to sell so we
ended up selling it to all the kids in
the dorms for the next three years we
would steal grapes from people's
Vineyards bootlegged under a bridge and
um and then just sell it to anybody that
had you know five ten bucks for a bottle
of wine when I was had to graduate the
idea to actually build a legit Winery
came around we raised a seed round
started building this company I brought
on two of my friends to help me do this
and it turned out to be one of the most
painful lessons I ever learned because a
year and a half later we're growing
really rapidly and
um so a year and a half later we're
growing really rapidly and we're no
longer friends we had what I like to
call the great divorce I don't know if
any of you guys have started or started
a company it's tough tough times and I
ended up selling the winery
so then took some time off goofed around
and decided to make another Winery to
get back into the business so I raised
this another seed round and started
building a product that I did not love
or care about at all and I was faking
this product I was trying to do what
everyone else in the space was doing
about that time I got into Adam Draper's
incubator and he took me aside and he
was like hey man what's going on like
you're struggling this is tough
you're not building anything that you
can actually get behind like build
something you can live and build
something you can love
so we ended up scrapping everything that
we were doing because I was faking it I
was building a product that I was faking
and everyone could see it it was so
obvious and
um so we scrapped what we were doing and
started over and it ended up costing
around thirty thousand dollars to get
rid of this product that we had already
started making and put out on the market
and that's when Rebel Coast my new
winery was born and it we decided to
build something that we could be really
passionate about and build a brand that
was really really enjoyable so that was
me up there and we ended up only making
one wine
and putting everything of our every part
of our personality into it and the goal
was to make something that would tell
our story even if we weren't there
um and we absolutely loved what we were
doing and the good thing about when you
love what you do you're more you've got
more leeway and everything so as a prank
I put my other two co-founders cell
phone numbers on about 10 000 corks each
and I didn't tell them about it and we
bottled this wine and it worked out
really well in our favor and it was
something really fun we did the good
thing is we're in a really Antiquated
archaic industry so if you go against
the grain in any way you get a lot of
attention and we ended up building a
cult following effortlessly overnight
and it's really helped Drive everything
that we're doing and the good thing
about that is in any industry that
anybody's in attention's huge and it
didn't cost us a dollar to get this huge
amount of attention that we got and it
wasn't just for the wine we were making
like that was a secondary thing
everybody was excited about why why we
were doing this
um to this day we still get unsolicited
a couple hundred resumes a month and
it's from people who have never heard
about or never even tasted our wine the
majority of them they're like hey what
you're doing looks really fun how do we
get into it and if you're building a
company getting people that are
interested in working with you and
helping build is awesome and this is a
traditional sales team on how people in
our industry normally sell wine and it
is we learned very fast that this was
not us and that nobody could sell wine
better than us so we cloned ourselves
and built a sales team this is half of
our team you know this couple of six
months ago
um but we just in not a single one of
these people is in this for the paycheck
that they get they're in it because they
love what they're doing they love being
around us because we're passionate about
everything the good news is if you're
passionate about something not only do
other people see it but potential
investors see it and it makes it a lot
easier to bridge that gap between hey I
need money and hey do you want to be
part of this so we've been able to Great
to gather a great group of investors to
help us get started and that's very true
with even Kickstarter campaigns the most
successful ones are because people are
funding why someone's doing something
not the actual end product so if you can
incorporate that into your actual
business it makes life a lot easier
um speaking of easy I know everybody's
you know either started a company or
fundraised or trying to fundraise it's
very very difficult don't let anyone
ever tell you otherwise and if you can
have just a little bit more passion in
what you're doing then it's going to
make life a lot easier uh that's pretty
much it for my speech I tricked my
co-founder to taking this picture so I
wanted to work it in here and
but yeah if you passionate about what
you're doing then life's going to be a
lot easier and everyone's going to see
it and people are going to want to be
around you and help you out along the
way
foreign